for the giants scott casmir the starter
now he may not
stay in there for very long we don't
know gabe capra did say before the game
that there are no restrictions there's
no pitch count he'll stay in there as
long as he's effective as long as he
looks good wilson contreras getting set
to lead things off the liner shallow
right falling in for a base hit cubs
begin the game
with a single and chris bryant will come
up against kasmir here it's bryant who's
hitting 404 against lefties third
highest in mlb and brian just having an
outstanding year overall that is crushed
left field that one back there on its
way and that one is gone
chris bryant pulls it and crushes it
over the left field wall and no doubter
and that quickly it is two nothing
anthony rizzo steps in here's a swing by
rizzo and a pop-up shallow right field
coming in as talkman and he'll get there
with the wind pushing it talkman makes
the catch the wind is going to be a
factor tonight
that is out number one
and javi baez will come up swing and a
miss strike three on the change up well
thrown by kasmir and so give kashmir
credit after that bryant home run he's
bounced back and he's gotten both rizzo
and baez two down and up comes the
former st mary's gail patrick wisdom
that's hammered into left field that
could be extra bases it gets past
dickerson and banks against the wall
wisdom to second and he's got a double
dubs with their third hit in the opening
inning let's see if jack peterson can
drive in wisdom who stays hot swings and
misses strike three kasmeer got him
jake arietta on the hill tonight for the
cubs arietta 35 years old and he is in
his 10th year at the big league level on
the mound to make his 11th start he's
five and five he's had a decision in
every start this year lamont wade jr
playing first base again tonight for the
giants fly ball to left
routine for peterson now drifting back
and he makes the catch he may have lost
that in the sky man
that ball definitely got a push from the
wind so one out here's alex dickerson
and that's a walk
for dickerson and comes buster posey
on the ground let's see if they can turn
it there's one
there's two
well that'll work jay garrietta using
the sinker to get the ground out it's
gonna be a lead off double opposite
field for brandon crawford
now emma montgorio will come up a chance
to drive in a run and the giants can get
one closer there's a ground ball base
hit into center field crawford scores
standing
and the cubs lead is 2-1 on the base hit
by evan longoria so now steven duggar
very confident player right now playing
the best baseball of his big league
career blasted to right field this one
is hit hard and it is gone
up onto that tin roof a line drive home
run that just stayed in the air
and stephen duggar has put the giants
ahead three to two
man that was impressive a very bumpy
beginning for arietta here in the second
inning alex dickerson will be the eighth
giant to bat in the end hit hard and
deep to right field this one is gone
alex dickerson goes deep this time a
three run homer for the giants it's six
to two file that one under the category
of annoying for gabe kepler lead off
walk four run lead and a power hitter
coming up jack peterson coming up now
here's where the cubs could use a long
ball that's drilled out to left there's
some damage that one back off the wall
and gone
jack peterson the other way
it's a two-run homer and the cubs right
back in it jason vossler who was
originally drafted by the cubs against
his old organization that's a good spot
for vossler because he does have power
hit that one pretty hard to center field
really hard half all the way back it's
gone
second big league home run and against
the team that drafted him and don't
think
he doesn't know that and here is lead
off man lamont wade jr wade takes one
deep down the right field line and it is
on that roof
another home run for the giants
amazing their fourth home run
in four innings tonight well it comes in
business here in the top half of the
fifth inning men at the corners no outs
and anthony rizzo at the plate oh two
and a little
tapper mattel made sure that contreras
was going to stay put
and then got the out at first contreras
has to stay at third one away here in
the top half of the fifth inning runners
at second and third for the cubs and the
cleanup man javier baez due up chopped
on the ground to the right side to get a
run home contreras comes in to score and
it's eight five so hobby knocks in a run
bryant down to third and they're two
outs
patrick wisdom at the plate this at that
a pretty big one in this game it's only
the fifth inning it really does
wisdom strikes out swinging that was a
perfect high fast ball
and littell did a great job of limiting
the damage a sinking liner that the left
fielder tried to
catch with a diving effort it bounced
off his body and carried way out to deep
left center cubs have a man at third
with two down
eric sogart has been sent to the plate
to pinch hit 2-2
sogar chops it to second
solano waited for the true hop and
throws him out so with two outs a single
and now a walk and now longoria
that's lying caught bobby with the play
a bullet and his shortstop was able to
grab it on the backhand
and he stole a hit from evan longoria
and a run from the giants eight five
into six two down here's anthony rizzo
o2 pitch is hit on the ground up the
middle diving to his left crawford
stands up throws to first he got him
what a play
oh my goodness brandon crawford just
totally robbed anthony rizzo
on a smash that was headed for center
field that was like an optical illusion
the ball was by him and he reached
backwards into the outfield and took a
hit away
what a play randy crawford you watch
contreras frustrated taking his
equipment off
david ross the manager comes over here's
anthony rizzo and now contreras
and rizzo having some words david ross
stepping between
and obviously they're both a little
frustrated no idea what that was about
in the heat of battle things happened
two down and out comes buster posey
posey bouncing one toward the middle
baez gloves spins throws gets him
rizzo stayed on the bag excellent play
by
piez and the inning is over good play by
rizzo on the other end tyler rogers in
for the pen all right here we go ninth
inning giants three outs away from a
second straight win against the first
place cubs two down comes down to their
last chance ground ball to second
dubon's got it and the game is over the
giants make it two in a row against the
cubs